hello everyone and welcome to a truly
spectacular game from the penultimate
round of the road to Miami FTX
preliminaries it is arjunergesi versus
Jeffrey xiong two of the young players
who are dominating the event so far
alongside the Samuel Sevin uh and it's a
game that really teaches us many things
like how far chess says chess has gotten
how much it has evolved how important it
is the let's say castle early and how
dangerous the London system really is so
let's dive straight into it it's a
really short game uh so uh you know
careful when playing against the London
and when playing the London so here
irrigation opens with Ponte D4 we have
Knight to F6 by xiong a bishopter F4 D5
and E3 going for the London setup with
Knight to F3 and Knight to D2 maybe C3
C4 uh Ponte E6 Knight to F3 and C5
striking against the White Center here
Knight beat the D2 and now usually black
plays Knight the c600 bishop to D6 the
Contour white strong dark Square Bishop
but here we have Queen to B6 uh
developing the queen early on going
after that B2 pawn and here uh there is
a well there are a couple of games that
have reached this position for example
very often plays this uh Rook to B1 is
the move that he plays uh he defeated
Dominguez with it he lost the game to
ding with it so it's a it's a known
position but here we have Pawn to C4 and
it is now already as of move six that we
have a completely new game so what's the
idea behind the pawn push well uh can
you capture the pawn let's uh cap crit
uh and see what happens well you can but
then uh White has a variety of options
he can just play Rook to B1 get free
development in and since it's a rapid
game maybe it's not something uh
uh something to go for and the black
king still has the uh uh Castle you have
to develop the bishop and Castle King
side so although it can be played you
don't really gain anything by it so
instead after the C4 move we have C
characters on D4 uh E Capture Sunday for
in the now the characters on C4 Knight
captures on C4 now attacking the queen
and here uh the safest uh move is the uh
most uh uh most of or rather the the
most obvious movie is the strongest one
and that is the queen back to d8 but
here we have Bishop to B4 check and this
is where Shinx troubles really start
with Bishop back to D2 Bishop captures
with check Queen captures and now as the
black queen is still under attack Queen
back to d8 you don't really have a a
better Square for the queen this is
covered by the queen this is covered by
the pawn discovered by the Knight so you
have to go back to d8 so Queen to d8 and
now there is one move that pretty much
ensures the victory for white already on
move 11. so feel free to pause the video
and try to find this move while I give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on keeping the black
king in the center of the board and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Queen to B4 that's the good
stuff we we cut off the black king from
castling and there isn't a way for black
to do something about this you could go
after the queen let's say you go Knight
to C6 but we still keep control of this
diagonal Queen to E3 and the ones Queen
t7 is played we play Knight to D6 check
now it's similar to what actually
happened in the game in the game we have
Queen to E7 right away now in case he
goes for Knight to D6 with check King to
f8 uh other uh were Retreats by the king
are even worse if you go here than
Knight E5 now threatens Knight to F7
checks so here you you can just resign
so okay the f8 and the now Knights the
E5 at least now not threatening any any
weird checks uh so everybody you are
attacking the F7 Pawn so Knights the C6
attacking the queen and the Knight here
but just Queen to A3 and it looks like
you could eliminate one of the attackers
the problem is after it captures and
captures you don't really gain all that
much with this okay Knight the D5 but
still you have a king and a f8 you're
gonna have
um a terrible time uh developing your
pieces white can play pretty much
anything in the attack the Knight here
go Castle's King side uh and the just um
uh start uh well further developing the
pieces so instead after Queen to A3 we
have Knight captures on D4 grabbing the
pawn here threatening Knight to C2 with
a monster Royal Fork here uh or rather
it's it's a family Fork I believe is the
correct term but now just Queen side
castles uh this also comes with tempo as
the Knight now is hanging Knight back to
C6 and now Knight E captures on F7 so
here uh you can see that uh black is
really without without a move the Rook
is attacked you have to play Rook to G8
now comes Bishop to C4 look at this the
knights here on D6 and F7 The Bishop's
slicing This Way Queen slicing this way
and the Rooks are controlling the open
files this Rook is still not controlling
default but it is coming to E1 and it's
uh well it's like something you would
see in a position from the Paul morphe
era so here Bishop to D7 and of course
Rook H the E1 uh White fully mobilized
this pieces and black can only wait and
see what happens so here uh Knight the
E8 offering a trade of knights but now
Queen to H3 uh probably trying to beat
the E6 so he can go after the H7 Pawn
but here we have Knight the d8 now with
a double attack on the F7 Knight and
here it's too easy to play this white
just trades the Knight capture 78 Rook
captures on the 8 and here Knight
captures and E8 and he was in this
position on move 21 that Jeffrey xiong
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here so truly a
spectacular display of the of the power
of the London system against an uncastle
King I mean this is just uh so so
quickly everything that could have gone
wrong has gone wrong for black Whitehead
full mobilization of his forces and I
mean how often do you see a position
like this on move 21 between such a
strong players the problem is if you
capture with the King then we just go
here Bishop captures on E6 and now a
Black's position just falls apart
there's really nothing to be done here
and instead if you go for Rook captures
uh it seems like it's a little bit
better but let's say queen F3 check and
that's it you don't have a move with the
King you have to play Queen F7 or queen
to F6 but whatever you play it's a free
Bishop root capture Sandy seven and
black resigns due to severe loss of
material
uh so after night capture 78 xiong
resigned and a brilliant brilliant
Victory uh for Azure navigation in this
penultimate round of the FTX wrote the
Miami preliminaries uh we'll see how it
goes we're going to show at least one
more game from the final round and then
we are going to discuss the standings uh
what is happening and who is advancing
to the main event uh as only 8 out of 16
players are advancing so a brilliant
brilliant game hope you guys enjoyed it
and always take good care when facing
the London system uh you have to have
something uh well uh nicely prepared
against it uh so yeah that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it I would like to
thank Stephen Abrams David bacon
ravishing reptiles YouTube and Gregory
piateski for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here and thank
you for watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event until it finishes so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day